firstly people people are amazing here
super hospitable they give you their
time that got out of the way to help
I've had great experiences with the
locals here and so it's one of those
places where if you land alone
you'll make friends it's not hard to
make friends here natural beauty the
landscapes here are stunning some of the
most beautiful sights I've seen in the
world there's a lake issyk-kul here
which no words or video can describe you
have to go experience it's it's just
massive and raw and rugged and beautiful
empty beaches massive Peaks yeah
landscapes are fantastic culture it's a
very interesting mix here I mean most
people are Kyrgyz but there there are a
minority of Russians and some other
minorities and which makes for an
interesting dynamic you know it feels
somewhat like you're in Asia but then
sometimes it feels like you're in more
of a European sphere yeah it's in that
part of the world sort of in-between
everything the geographic location here
is super interesting if you look on a
map China's not far away that way to the
south Tajikistan Afghanistan Pakistan to
the north Kazakhstan Russia so it's in
this part of the world where well a lot
of powers have come through here and
shaped it to what it is today and pretty
much go into one direction and and be in
a completely completely different place
costs its 2018 summer 2019 have to say
it's inexpensive so what do I mean by
that the other day I hit a guy we drove
for almost 13 hours around us he called
stopped into the mountains down to
Bishkek and I think I paid him eighty
dollars that will give you some of the
gauge on the transport cost and that
that was my own personal vehicle take
Yandex which is the best way to get
around I found in the city it's very
inexpensive UK need a great meal for
roughly around a dollar so it's
it's your money goes very far if you're
coming in with a dollar euro yen or some
stronger currency food food is food is
good they have this one dish near the
Chinese border is it seemed to be pretty
popular
arsalan Phu noodle dish you can get all
different ways but noodles eggs a very
spicy broth if you love mutton you'll
love this place because they use a lot
of mutton history
I don't know much of the history I've
know the basics but you can tell just by
traveling the country there's a lot of
layers to peel back here and if you
really want to get into this culture I
think you could be busy with reading up
on your history for quite some time it's
it's a very very very fascinating corner
of the globe and it feels very much like
a corner in a sense words if you're
coming in from Asia or from Europe it's
just far it's far removed from most
things safety I've felt safe the whole
time it's got the word stand at the end
of a country and that's a curse because
most people associate that with
terrorism they associate it with danger
I've been told there's some bad parts of
Bishkek on the outskirts I haven't been
to those parts but where I've been in
Bishkek mostly in the centre it's
totally cool to walk around here it
feels very safe and in the countryside
it felt very safe sure things can happen
but for the most part I think it's it's
completely fine now it is you know the
stands are interesting the sense that
you know throughout history there have
been flash points and hot points that
have come up and so do your research
know where you're going but to be an
alarmist over and and feel like it's all
super dangerous is is
a little bit ridiculous to be honest
because once you're here you'll realize
it's quite a civilized place
architecture the architecture here
depends what you like but the
architecture is stunning and so if you
like some of them older Soviet stuff
that constructivism that Brutalism then
you found you found your heaven because
this place has some real gems and then
there's also like the the yurts those
are really cool if you haven't seen
yurts before so there's yurts up in the
countryside up in the mountains and so
I've been told these massive yurts can
be put up in like 30 minutes
transportation super easy to get around
I came in from Almaty it was just a
shared taxi which these shared taxis are
really interesting in this part of the
world you basically go to part of the
city usually near the bus station and
well you wait for a car to fill up
you're all going to one destination each
person pays a fee and you wait for you
wait for it to fill up and then you're
on a road trip together and it's cool
like depending on the car you're in it
can be really connected it can be really
fun he's most likely you'll stop for
lunch together and it's a really good
way to sit get into the culture at a
deeper level because you're you're
forced to be sitting with four or five
strangers for a
if you're thinking about it definitely
put this place on your radar it's it's
fantastic it's really a cool place to
travel it's a bit wild it's got some
adventure in it but it's civilized and
set up well enough where it's it's
pretty easy travel yeah I mean even the
the cellphone plans work really well and
are cheap
Internet's good that's my take on
Kyrgyzstan definitely one of the cool
corners of the world
[Music]
you